someday love will find you break those
chains that bind you
hello everyone
[Laughter]
and welcome back we are basically
finishing up clone conspiracy right i
think we did the last video we're like
you know what instead of dragging this
on for another week let's just exit
right now let's just get it done and out
of the way right so we can kind of move
on to the really cool stories like when
the green goblin became carnage yes the
green goblin
became carnage in marvel comics and it
was amazing okay so we are opening
things up here with basically a
spider-man just fleeing for his life
being chased by what are in effect
zombies only for us to find out this is
scarlet spider i.e kane now who is kane
okay so kane as we talked about in the
last video appeared in what was the
original clone saga uh but unlike ben
reilly who was more in line with like
the life philosophies of peter parker
right like not killing if he doesn't
have to kane was a dick this guy was
like the punisher man this this dude
would kill people with no real
reservation right this guy was pretty
hardcore and really if i'm being honest
i think it's one of the things that
always kept him popular in marvel comics
he was an answer to the question what if
spider-man became a punisher but in a
lot of ways he was um maybe not
necessarily as like horrible as the
punisher especially if you read punisher
max right uh we need to get back on that
when we finish invincible over a patreon
because god man you know this is this is
one of those things where cain was
always kind of an anti-hero type
spider-man right and people love that
the problem is he's kind of running
through this this strange universe where
everything's popping off only for him to
wake up and kind of be met with quote
unquote their guest who of course is
looking for their pills now as far as
the pills go that'll be explained here
in a minute instead what we do is we
actually switch back over to uh peter
parker inside the new you facility of
course being attacked by dr octopus and
gwen stacy now the biggest issue here is
what's going on with gwen stacy and
what's going on with dr octopus the
doctor octopus has in effect returned
we're not given a definitive answer in
terms of how he's actually been able to
do it but one of the things here is that
he recalls everything and so when peter
parker looks at this from the
perspective of the fact that dr octopus
favorite may very well be a clone in his
mind his knowledge of clones goes back
to the clone saga where they have kind
of a limited memory uh because they're
duplicates of a particular person but
they don't really know the the kind of
ins and outs of what their life should
be in the sense that dr octopus if he
has a clone would have limited memory
because there's no way jackal could know
everything about the life and times of
dr octopus right duplicating genetic
memory is a virtually impossible thing
to do and so because of that he's kind
of like okay there's something off here
right because when he challenges the
knowledge of doctor octopus he says no i
remember everything from the time that i
took over your body in superior
spider-man to the time that you told me
you were from my future in spider-verse
and i learned you were eventually going
to get your body back right to the point
that i eventually died and then took
over the body of a computer system using
technology from the future in marvel
2099 right the home reality of miguel
o'hara uh spider-man 2099 right using
that technology developing a body for
myself right now the living brain he's
like i remember everything right i am dr
octopus like i am the auto octavius that
you know the problem is even with this
it kind of stretches the limits of
cajulity because he's like i don't know
how in the world you could possibly be
back enter miles warren the jackal the
crazy thing about this is it looks like
there's three of them right there's
literally the jackaloos kind of running
the show and then there's two other
versions of miles warren which is kind
of wild right it's kind of a crazy thing
but with gwen stacy able to kind of talk
peter parker down a little bit then it
turns into okay let's find out what's
actually going on here right and so what
we're really given here the way that the
jackal presents this to peter is it's
not really one of these things where the
jackals looking to clone people for the
sake of just like messing up people's
lives or causing problems he's actually
looking to do some genuine good in the
world one of the first things he does
here which is probably the wrong thing
to do is he basically presents
spider-man with all the villains who
have died at the hands of peter parker
or by virtue of peter parker's actions
right but all these different villains
who have been killed over the years and
it's kind of nuts because he's kind of
like why in the world would you bring
all these guys back like you know like
peter parker immediately expects a fight
right like he's immediately expecting a
fight to break out and it's just kind of
like okay uh all right let's do this
right let's let's let's do this right
now and of course they're kind of like
look man we're not really here to to
fight you know they're we're not really
here to cause problems man like we're
just kind of here we're kind of glad you
know that jackal brought us back
why are you trying to start stuff man
that's basically their response right
now in the middle of this whole thing
when the jackal basically reveals that
because of the fact that they've been
brought back as clones in order to keep
the villains from just running out a
muck in the world and just causing all
kinds of problems that they basically
have to pop pills in order to keep their
bodies from breaking down the way jackal
describes it they're on a kind of
chemical leash but so long as jackal is
the sole person that holds their pills
they have to come to him which means
they have to do whatever he says and in
this instance he's saying don't go tear
up the world right just basically you
know hang out around here just do what i
tell you to but in the middle of this
whole thing everything pops off and
immediately captain stacy the father of
gwen stacy is like okay you thought of
every single last detail right and miles
warren is like yes and he's like here's
the problem man that's not my daughter
gwen stacy i know my daughter gwen stacy
anywhere that's not her what have you
done with her only for us to find out
it's spider-gwen man what a great change
right it's spider gwen right gwen stacy
from earth 65 who basically gained the
powers of a spider instead of peter
parker it's amazing spider gwen's a
character who should never have been
popular in the first place right here's
the funny thing about this spider gwen
gained popularity not because of her
stories right her story was edge of
spider-verse it was it was kind of cool
right not a whole lot going what made
her popular was the costume that's what
made her popular right like her spider
suit it made her like one of the most
popular things ever after that like she
was cosplayed everywhere you guys
remember that when spider gwen first
came out in edge of spider-verse and you
went to like new york comic-con and san
diego and emerald city and c2e2 and like
everybody was cosplaying as spider-gwen
that's what made her popular right now
her stories are great but it was the art
that really set her off and made her
into a really cool character of course
she's basically here peter parker is
like oh awesome cool the last time we
teamed up we were fighting the
inheritors but uh she's basically a good
guy let's get out of here
so they basically escaped the lizards
sent after them and then we basically
pick up with kane only to find out that
he's actually the one that has the real
the not really the real the clone gwen
stacy the one that was brought back by
miles warren of course he's got her all
tied up and everything but he reveals
and when the questions ask why aren't
you bringing in peter parker on all this
right i mean if spider-man is the hero
here and you and spider-gwen are
basically working together she's well at
least was basically pretending to be
spider-gwen is at the new you facility
to gain information why aren't you guys
telling peter parker about this and he
says because we've seen this whole thing
happen right this whole clone conspiracy
we've seen all this happen we've seen
all of it play out in different
universes across the multiverse and it
all ends the same way peter parker
allies himself with the jackal new you
and parker industries go global they end
up unleashing what isn't affecting the
carry-on virus and they basically kill
the world and that's kind of the nuts
thing here right now a lot of you guys
are probably asking what in the hell is
the carry-on virus okay so what you end
up learning here is that the carry-on
virus and honestly there's been like
five different versions of the virus
originally miles warren was an employee
or a guy who worked for the high
evolutionary who's basically a guy that
literally uses evolution to just speed
up the process of growing life and
things like that he's super smart right
like herbert wyndham's super smart he's
capable of all kinds of cool stuff he's
usually a villain sometimes he's a hero
right it really kind of depends but the
first carry-on virus like pretty much
all the other versions that came after
while it did have different origins in
terms of who created it or how it was
synthesized or what have you it all
basically serves the same purpose it
turns people into effect living corpses
now how it works here is a little bit
different than what you've seen in
different carry-on viruses over the
years in marvel comics but basically the
carry-on virus is the result of new you
and peter parker working together
allowing the whole thing to kind of
spread across the world and then
basically killing all life on that world
now the idea of cellular degradation it
all kind of starts out as basically
people who are clones they eventually
become carriers their bodies break down
but during the cellular degradation
process they become infectious and they
infect other people and those other
people end up becoming carry-ons now
ultimately the entire process will break
down right it'll all basically end and
the world will basically die but it's
one of these things where spider-man
basically kills the world and all these
different universes that kane and
spider-gwen have been in which is why
they're not bringing him in because
their fear is if they tell him what's
going on that he'll ultimately end up
siding with with uh with new you
technologies where it might send him on
the path of doing it and basically
solidify the end of the world in the
main marvel universe right so what they
end up doing is basically calling a
woman by the name of chief anderson
right chief anderson kind of working
with the cops the one that's handling
all the new used stuff and she's like
cool we'll respond only for us to find
out she's actually part of new you she's
popping the pills to keep herself from
breaking down she's a clone and so what
you end up doing is picking up with the
jackal back at new you headquarters as
they kind of transition and he kind of
shows peter parker what's going on there
is this thing called like the ultimate
prototype right this kind of ultimate
clone body that they don't really do
anything with to be honest uh you don't
really see much of it play out in this
particular story but it's one of these
things where you have like spider gwen
you've got uh peter parker trying to
figure out what's going on trying to
meet with kane only to find out that
horizon university is under attack they
get there but along the way peter keeps
asking you know spider gwen what's going
on here how come you guys never brought
me in and she keeps dodging the question
she won't give him a definitive answer
and so finally she dumps it to him right
because she knows peter parker well
enough to know that he's gonna stop
asking and he's gonna start demanding
right he's gonna start getting pissed
off and so her response is okay look
here's the deal man like here's what
happened basically everything that i
just told you guys with regards to kane
that's basically what she says and the
response of peter is no that's never
gonna happen right but the problem is
she says like the jackal in every one of
these universes always finds a way he
always finds a way to basically get you
to switch to his side but in the midst
of all this in the aftermath of
basically electro rhino showing up to
horizon university attacking everything
snatching up the the clone gwen stacy
bringing her back the response is okay
we have to launch a strike against new
you and they're met by the arrival of
the kingpin now the whole reason why the
kingpins here is because what had
happened prior to this during the events
of before dead no more is you ended up
learning that the jackal had approached
the kingpin and basically looked to have
him work directly with uh with with the
jackal because of the kingpin's
resources and he had done this or at
least tried to get this to happen by
basically bringing back vanessa right
the long dead wife of wilson fisk wilson
fisk immediately killed the clone and
was like you are now my mortal enemy i
will do everything i can to destroy you
now the reason why the jackal did this
is because the jackal the smartest thing
he could have done here is exactly what
he did do when he basically started
going through and and kind of
approaching people who were in high
positions of power government officials
members of the press right what you
would normally expect billionaires to do
and kind of buying off these different
members of society that jackal had
actually done that by using what was in
effect emotional blackmail by
approaching these guys and basically
saying here's the deal uh i will
resurrect your loved one right i will
bring your loved one back to you or i
will i will do this for you or do that
for you or something along those lines
but you will owe me right and that's how
he basically ended up developing all
these people in powerful positions that
could essentially make things happen for
him now the funny thing about this is
that this kind of revelation to a degree
with regards to peter parker hasn't
necessarily come yet instead you end up
having peter meeting with the jackal or
at least intercepting a meeting between
the jackal and a few guys based on
information given to him by the kingpin
and when he arrives on the scene a fight
breaks out the funny thing about this is
the jackal is able to outmaneuver and
and basically evade peter parker in
seemingly every way in fact they're
fighting at a dead even keel and it's
kind of nuts because peter's like no no
something isn't right here right like
you are not you're not the miles warren
that i remember right the jackal was i
mean he was capable but he was never on
my level in terms of speed durability
being able to punch me that hard he was
never ever on this level who are you
really and that's when the jackery moves
his helmet and it's ben riley it's ben
riley's spider-man it's the other clone
of peter parker now this is the crazy
thing right this this is this is a crazy
thing because while we're not explicitly
told in this story how it happened
here's how ben riley ends up becoming
basically the jackal ends up leading the
whole thing right so the idea here is
that because ben reilly was one of the
clones of peter parker created by miles
warren back during the original clone
saga that miles warren was kind of up to
his old tricks again right phoning
people different things like that what
he ended up doing was resurrecting or
basically cloning ben reilly but his
cells would break down at a rapid pace
because he was trying to find a more
effective way to develop cloned bodies
and so essentially ben reilly was cloned
and died and cloned and died over and
over and over and over again and so once
ben reilly had basically become
stabilized then riley actually broke
free and then took over and essentially
knocked miles warren unconscious and
then cloned the jackal and then
basically screwed with his mind the same
way jackal screwed with ben riley's mind
back during the original clone saga and
convinced both versions of miles warren
that they actually worked for him that
he's the one running the show he was
able to kind of modify their memories a
little bit and different things like
that but that's why miles warren is
basically not actually running anything
it's been riley now the fact that ben
reilly and them also have kane at their
disposal all that kind of stuff going on
they're basically kind of doing their
own thing right kind of going forward
and so on but with peter parker kind of
realizing okay this has been riley he
gets a bit of a reprieve and a lot of
this is really because of the fact that
pierre wants to know what's actually
going on because ben reilly was very
similar to himself you know ben reilly
died in the arms of peter parker right
like he literally turned to dust and
faded away and so with these guys it's
one of these things where it's kind of
like okay look you're not a normal
villain it's one of these things where
he's kind of like i'm genuinely curious
what's going on here like i genuinely
want to know what's happening and so
what ends up taking place here is that
where ben riley initially introduced
peter parker to the underground all the
different villains that have been
brought back instead what he actually
ends up doing here is bringing him to a
place called the haven basically all
these people who have been brought back
you know kind of the there's the villain
group but this is basically kind of home
for everybody who's been resurrected and
it's one of these things where he's like
i brought back kirk connor's wife and
son right i've brought back a lot of the
people that you know who have died i
brought back jay jonah jameson's wife
i'm not here for the purpose of just
conquering the world by using subterfuge
and things like that i'm legitimately
trying to do a good thing now peter's
you know really his huge reluctance to
this is no like i can't really get on
board with this and the crazy thing is
the only reason peter's even here is yes
one part of it has to do with loyalty to
the idea of ben reilly but also because
ben said we can bring back uncle ben we
can resurrect uncle ben from the dead
right we can clone him and bring him
back and you can have him back in your
life we can even bring back the guy who
killed uncle ben so you can smack him
around a little bit if you want to right
but he's like you know we can we can
make the world right again the funny
thing about this is peter you know after
seeing all this and it's really more of
his desire to just find out how deep it
goes right it's more of like a recon
mission than actually siding with ben
reilly if anything he was just
pretending he's just like no you're not
gonna bring back uncle ben and he's like
why wouldn't i bring back uncle ben i
have the technology to do it he was like
if you were going to you would have
because you are me and uncle ben means
as much to you as he does to me right so
if you were going to bring him back it
would have been one of the first things
you did and you would have known and
like knowing me as you know me you would
have known uncle ben would have been the
person to bring back not gwen stacy
because while it is cool to see her
again uncle ben's return could get me to
do almost anything he's like but at the
end of the day i know why you wouldn't
do it because uncle ben would look at
you the way that uncle ben only could
and tell you you're wrong yes you have
the means to do it but you don't have
any responsibility here and with great
power must come great responsibility
standing in the face of ben writing like
that and just being like i was never
going to be a part of this right i was
never going to join you on this i just
wanted to see how deep it goes kind of
revealing this here ben reilly realizes
that peter parker is never going to join
his side and someone responds ben
riley's like kill him and everybody goes
after spider-man right everybody starts
attacking him and that's the crazy thing
because at that point hobie brown while
he is technically a clone and he is kind
of under the the service of the jackal
he he still has a measure of free will
right it's not really mental control so
much as it is you've got to take my
pills otherwise you're going to die so
as a result of that hobie brown the
prowler who of course was basically the
not really the the sidekick what kind of
the sidekick of spider-man at one point
in time ends up helping him kind of face
off against the the various villains and
then you end up having jackal who
basically leaves and goes to uh speak
with with anna marconi and goes to speak
with like electro and doctor octopus and
those guys now one thing to keep in mind
anna marconi's not sided with the jackal
she was basically brought here right
against her will but it's one of these
things where you basically have her in a
kind of revelation with dr octopus where
as much as she despises him now because
of the fact that he's a villain that he
realized okay so whenever any of the
clones step outside the facility of new
you they start breaking down at a much
faster pace why because there's some
kind of a radio signal out there that
basically breaks them down right maybe
it's fm radio maybe it's am radio maybe
it's just some kind of of you know part
of the light spectrum whatever it
happens to be it forces them to break
down faster which is why they break down
slower when when they're here and he's
like so if there is a radio signal out
there that speeds up the breakdown
process then there's got to be a signal
that slows it down right that could
almost bring it to an end and so that's
when the two of them were kind of
talking and they're like okay animal
crony's like i figured it out right when
miles warren's here she's like i figured
out how to stop the entire breakdown
process to completely end it now in
response to this the jackal is like if
you give me that information because
marconi is like i'm not she's not
readily gonna give it to him when he's
like if you give me this information i
will give you this ultimate clone body
right we'll put you in a body that's not
diminutive right that's rid of any
defects things like that now one of the
best things about anna marconi is she's
like i don't want that garbage she was
always like a really confident woman
right highly intelligent highly
confident and didn't really need to like
feel satisfied right i mean she had
basically been satisfied with herself
she's like i know what i'm capable of i
know what i'm about i don't need to be
in a body of a quote unquote big person
in order to feel like i'm making an
impact on the world i'm literally
smarter than you are right so if
anything you need to get on my level bro
good for you girl right good for you but
nonetheless because of the fact that
that the jackal makes this offer to anna
it pisses off dr octopus who immediately
goes to attack him and then he realizes
that that jackal is not actually miles
warren that has been riley because of
the fact that his spider sense alerts
him and allows him to react proactively
to the tentacles of doctor octopus and
so he's like okay that's when it all
starts popping off because while
everything is going on right spider gwen
shows up she's trying to rescue kane
she's kind of a distraction doctor
octopus is like no we're destroying
everything that you care about and so he
ends up amplifying the signal that
speeds up the cellular degradation of
the clones throughout the entirety of
the new year facility and literally all
these clones start dying and breaking
down the problem with this is this is
how it begins that when a person
physically touches somebody who is in
possession of the carry-on virus that
they basically become a carrier
themselves right they become infected by
it it's not like a zombie infection
where you have to be bitten all you have
to do is be touched and that's the end
of it right that's enough of it that's
how kane ended up looking the way that
he does is because in one of these
alternate realities when he was looking
to escape from uh from from the the
carry-on plague as it was spreading
throughout that world he was just
touched by somebody with a carry-on
virus right now the spider abilities
this healing factor that kind of thing
kind of helps keep it at bay and even
then he has to kind of keep himself
doped up in order to keep the virus from
completely overtaking his body but this
is how it spreads the biggest problem
with this is that the signal is
basically amplified across the world and
so because of that you know with with
the jackal using his ability to take
what dr octopus has done and spread it
across the world he knows that all these
people who are clones are going to start
breaking down and they're all basically
going to start dying and people are
going to start touching them and they're
going to turn into carry-ons themselves
and as crazy as this idea is the whole
purpose of jackal is to basically kill
the world and then recreate it in a day
right which he could feasibly do now the
most likely scenario here is it wouldn't
play out that way because that's what
they that's what he tried to do in other
universes and it never worked the same
way right it never played out the way
that they wanted it to it basically just
led to the carry-on infection running
rampant throughout the planet and there
was no real discernible way to stop it
and so because of that peter's kind of
like okay right spider-man's like all
right i'll do what i can but at the end
of the day he's just got to watch all
these people kind of break down and die
there's not really a whole lot he can do
here right not much aid he can offer but
instead what ends up happening is that
he's like okay anna marconi is the
person i got to talk to i need to get to
her so we can figure out a solution here
gwen stacy despite the fact that she's
basically breaking down after being told
by your father uh captain stacy look
peter's a good guy right peter has
always been a great guy you have to help
him however it is that he needs help and
ultimately it's the last the really the
dying thing that gwen stacy does is get
peter parker to safety and she also ends
up shutting one of the doors and then
basically you know killing a bunch of
the villains that are clones in order to
buy peter parker time so she literally
sacrifices her life against like the
hobgoblin and jack-o'-lantern and the
green goblin she kills them all
just to basically save peter parker
which is kind of nuts and peter parker
along with spider-gwen and kane all end
up kind of banding together a little bit
right now at that point peter finds
jackal and immediately goes to attack
ben reilly but in the middle of all that
anna marconi's like no no we don't need
you fighting jackal right we don't need
you fighting ben reilly dr octopus can
handle him right he's fought you a
zillion times before ben riley's really
no different than you except he doesn't
really have any web shooters so at the
end of the day doctor octopus can handle
him i need your brain and that's when
peter realizes you found a way to
reverse the signal and so what ends up
happening here is because of the fact
that parker industries is essentially
just this giant worldwide corporation
that makes peter parker richer than tony
stark one of the things they developed
was webware right which is essentially a
marvel comics equivalent to like iphones
eye watches all that kind of stuff right
apple products that's really what parker
industries is in a lot of ways they have
they have a more expansive reach than
apple does right they're not just a
technology corporation that the dell's
in like computer technology and that's
basically it they've got a much larger
reach than that unlike apple they
actually care about people so the
important thing here is that peter
basically ends up really traveling to
the news station where j jonah jameson
was at which was hijacked by the jackal
in order to broadcast this signal across
the world and kind of speed up this
cellular degradation right because it's
one of these things where again when you
touch somebody with the with the
carry-on virus you're infected by it and
your cells start breaking down so at
this point it's not really a matter of
saving clones i mean they kind of can
but it's really more of just saving
everybody else and so using the
technology of webware and basically
sending out the reverse signal which
essentially slows down and eliminates
cellular breakdown they're basically
able to save pretty much everybody out
there any clone or anybody who is uh
who's been touched by a carry-on who's
not breaking down or who is who's only
just started breaking down essentially
survives for a lot of them out there
they're dead right there's there's not
really a whole lot that they can do here
everybody's kind of gone the other big
thing is that dr octopus actually ends
up just wrecking the entirety of the
facility while he's fighting ben reilly
and just has like this whole lash out
moment right he was like he's like you
know like like what you've done here
almost cost my anna her life right this
is huge because it's a testament to how
much dr octopus loved anna marconi right
how much he cared about her that he's
like okay like i'm destroying it all
right i mean in the end he is also kind
of breaking down himself and so he's
like okay he basically crushes destroys
the whole thing it all basically
explodes and he's like melt with me and
it's just like that's it right it
basically ends up he ends up taking out
ben reilly and himself in the process so
that all that's left is basically just
the the little ashes and remains of
doctor octopus and ben reilly's
basically gone right all the clones are
essentially eliminated here and so what
you end up getting here is this
revelation from a woman by the name of
uh of of dr clarkson and who basically
ends up bringing in like like spider-man
and anna and and kane and all these
different guys and basically says look
like here's here's the thing that was
going on right like i thought that ben
reilly was actually doing some good work
right i didn't realize that he really
had aspirations for doing villainous
stuff despite the fact that jackal has
historically been a villain of peter
parker common sense people it's time to
use it but she's like we thought we
thought he was actually doing good
things right but what she says here is
that not everybody out there that had
basically been killed was brought back
as a clone under the jackal for some of
them we were actually able to restore
them a little bit right you know
procedures different things like that we
were able to kind of bring them back not
everybody and the cloning procedure was
used really more by ben reilly to
solidify a position of power even if he
didn't want to openly admit it right but
she's like some of the people we were
able to bring back not a whole lot of
significant people here jerry salteras
is one of them but one thing i will say
do not forget about that ultimate clone
body because it has not been destroyed
and it will return in a really cool way
but with that being said guys this is
clone conspiracy it's a lot that happens
in a five issue series but it's the
clone conspiracy it's really good i
always really enjoyed it i always
thought it was a lot better but the
spider-man stories is as cool as this is
honestly i consider it to be one of the
weaker spider-man stories at least under
dan's slot what comes after this gets
amazing especially when green goblin
becomes carnage god it becomes
absolutely awesome anyway guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace